um this is a large project to
collectively analyze 2,800 tumor normal
whole genome sequence pairs and in
particular I'll talk about the mutation
calling aspect that I primarily been
involved in and after that we'll talk a
little bit about nanopore sequencing
upcoming sequencing technologies some of
the algorithms my group has been
developing for that sequencing platform
and in the applications towards cancer
genomics they were we're hoping to use
so I'll start with P cog so peacock is
very large international consortium it
has 16 working groups organized around
some theme of analysis of cancer genomes
those working groups have collectively
130 different research projects with
with 700 researchers involved from from
literally all around the world so this
this is a large collection of can of
whole genome sequence cancers so there's
already been pan-cancer projects focused
on exome sequencing to look at what
would exone sequencing tells us about
coding mutations and the goal of peacock
is really to expand this pan-cancer
analysis looking across different tumor
types at the non-coding genome and and
what whole genome sequencing tells us so
there's working groups involved in
looking at regulatory regions non-coding
RNAs large-scale genomic structural
changes mutations signatures evolution
heterogeneity and really any anything
that you could think of doing for a for
a cancer genome data set is is covered
by one of the working groups and I
imagine we'll hear some our results from
the p-dog project during this week so to
collectively analyze and do uniform data
processing of these 2,800 genomes we
need quite a lot of compute the the data
set weighs in at about 500 terabytes and
no single center was volunteering to do
all of the analysis for the peacock data
set so there's been a set of cloud
computing centers who have been
have been recruited to help process this
data in a distributed manner and these
are spread all around the world and
cover both academic computing clouds
like say the Barcelona supercomputing
Center and the ebiz London London data
center and also commercial vendors like
Amazon Web Services in both Ireland and
Oregon are contributing compute and
helping to host the data this all told
encompass about 16,000 cores of
computation power and about 60 terabytes
of RAM in aggregate so as I mentioned
the we'll probably hear other talks
about some of the downstream results of
what people have found from the just
peacock data set so I'm going to focus
on the process of finding somatic
mutations from the set of 2,800 genomes
so when the pan-cancer project was
starting they asked for abstracts from
research groups who wanted to do some
sort of computation on this data set and
there's a lot of interest of running
various mutation calling algorithms on
on the data set now despite the this
very large compute cloud that's been
arranged we couldn't run all of the
mutation calling pipelines on all 2800
genomes so with the pan-cancer steering
committee decided is that there'd be a
set of three core pipelines that would
be run on everything that's the the
Broad Institute mutation calling
pipeline the Sanger and DK of Zen
pipelines and then the remaining callers
of which there's about a dozen would be
run on a 50 sample subset of the 2800
genomes and from that 750 sample subset
we would do extensive validation of the
mutations with the goal of comparing the
the performance of the different
mutation calling pipelines and coming up
with an idea of how to construct a
consensus call set then merge is the
calls from the three core pipelines into
one with better properties and than any
individual caller so to do the
validation we did deep-sea tree
sequencing on aluminous we design an
image and capture array for about
130,000 mutation sites and then we re
sequence them in the tumor sample and
the normal cell
and every one of these points here is a
validated snv call and benefit of doing
extremely deep pre sequencing on alumina
is that we'd end up with about a
thousand X on average per site and we
can do fairly simple classification
between the calls that validate to be
true and the calls that validates be
false so this cluster of points here are
calls where there is much stronger
evidence in the tumor sample than the
normal and this line here where the VAF
sand the tumor normal i correlated are
things where there's not enough evidence
much more evidence in the tumor to say
that it's not a germline mutation so
once once we have our validation
classifications we can then starts
calculate precision and recall per
mutation calling pipeline so each point
here just mutation calling pipeline with
precision on the y-axis recall or
sensitivity on the x-axis and this is
for for substitution or single
nucleotide variant calls we see that the
major distinguishing factor between the
mutation cut pipelines is 44 snv's is
the sensitivity of the caller most
callers have very good precision they're
not making very many false calls but
they vary widely in their in their
ability to find the true mutations from
from the lowest sensitivity caller
having less than ten percent sensitivity
all the way up to the mutex pipeline was
very well tested substitution caller
having about ninety-eight percent
sensitivity now if we look at insertion
and deletion mutations we see a much
worse performance and this probably
doesn't come as a surprise to many of
you in that the meet the performance of
finding insertion and deletion mutations
is really all over the place we find
that some callers were able to find have
a fairly high precision for finding
insertions and deletions but none of
them have a very good sensitivity with
the best topping out at about 55 to 60
percent sensitivity this plot includes
all insertion and deletion mutations
that we try to validate including homo
polymer runs which are probably the most
difficult class of in Del mutations to
find if we restrict ourselves and not
including in dells and
strs we see somewhat better mutation
calling performance with some pipelines
having sensitivity over sixty sixty-five
percent but none of them doing a great
job unlike for substitutions and if we
look at structure variation again we see
very similar picture some pipelines
having a fairly decent precision but
none of them having extremely good
sensitivity it would push them up into
the top right of this plot where we'd
like to see the caller's so when I take
away from this is that despite all of
the the work on calling in dells and
structural variation we're still in
quite a difficult position where there's
not one dominant approach that we can
run and any get a comprehensive set of
variant calls for on a cancer genome I
think smv calling is largely a solved
problem there's some work maybe to be
done with low frequency mutations but in
general S&D calling is is in a much
better state than calling larger
mutations so I mean I was working
particularly on in dell calling using
assembly based approaches for the last
few years and I've started to think now
about how long reads like reads that are
ten thousand base pairs in length rather
than 100 base pairs in length are going
to improve the situation for finding
these more complex rearrangements and
the rest of my talk will be about how
we've been using nanopore data and a
building methods to analyze nanopore
sequencing data I'm not alone in this
idea that long reads are going to help
and in a way it's very obvious but I
just like to point out that Mike Schatz
as a group is on very nice job of
looking at how pacbio data which also
give you reads on the scale of ten
thousand bases will help find structure
variation and they've sequenced a breast
cancer cell line to two very high depth
and and I'll just visit there's a link
to his slides here that did not covers
that project so your four main reasons
i'm interested in a nap or sequencing
the first is that the sequencer is
extremely portable if you haven't seen
one the men I on sequencer is roughly
the size of this clicker you plug it
into a laptop with a USB cable and then
you just load a sample into the top of
it and it's sequences directly on your
bench top that
opens up a lot of new applications of
sequencing particularly in
resource-limited conditions or in
clinical sequencing labs where they
might not have the infrastructure to
support say an alumina sequencer like
pacbio the nanopore instrument gives you
extremely long reads you can sequence
ten thousand base pairs or even 50,000
base pair reads as long as you're
careful enough with a library prep and
the technology is also scalable the the
version of the sequence is very small it
has about 500 nanopores which sequence
in parallel the larger version of the
instrument that's currently in
prototyping has 140,000 pores at that
level of parallelization they should be
able to sequence human genomes and
cancer genomes using nap or technology
and the final thing and the thing I'm
most excited about is that nanopore
sequencing can directly detect base
modifications like methyl cytosine
without an additional assay like
bisulfite sequencing and I'll give some
results in just a few minutes here after
I talk about what not a poor data looks
like so here's a very nice illustration
that David Eccles made of what the setup
of a nanopore sequencing like so here we
have a membrane with the nanopore
embedded in the membrane and the DNA
passes through single-stranded through
the poor in this direction and as it
passes through its blocking the flow of
current of a conducting fluid from this
side of the membrane through here and
about 3,000 times a second three
kilohertz the amount of current that's
flowing through the pore is sampled by a
Pico ammeter and this current
measurement is the output of the
sequencer so unlike say alumina
technology which is based on fer essence
and step-by-step sequencing DNA you're
just getting this continuous measurement
of the amount of current that's being
blocked by the poor which is indicative
of the sequences that's in there and the
most important thing is that we're not
reading single bases here there the
length of this channel is is roughly say
five to six bases and the amount of
current this block is dependent on that
entire five to six base pair sequence
rather than just single bases and that's
the primary challenge of analyzing down
onboard data so again here's what it
looks like in a different form we have
our nanopore here there's some sequence
in it and there as the currents being
measured it's read out like this in
samples over time so here we have a boat
say the current measurement is about 60
p collapse once a new sequence move
through the pore the current signal
might change then change again change
again change again as the the sequence
goes through there we see these jumps
and current depending on what the
sequence is now we don't work with the
raw samples from the nanopore sequencer
onboard the hardware there's an
algorithm that segments the current into
what's called events and an event is
just a long a group of the individual
samples that where the the segmentation
algorithm has thought that it hasn't
changed over that time and the output of
the sequencer is therefore a table in an
hdf5 file where we have a group of
events and with each one having its mean
current estimated the standard deviation
and the time or the duration of those
individual events and that's the data
that we actually are able to work on
right now in my last slide I'm going to
talk about the open problems and one of
the open problems is modeling the
duration of each event to recover things
like homo polymer runs the enzyme
performance tends to stutter so
sometimes you'll have a very long event
that's it should be roughly exponential
but sometimes you get much longer events
than expected which is one of the
challenges of trying to say how long how
long the the sequence was they move
through for each event so right now I
don't think anybody is actually modeling
the events and we don't assume that it's
that it's roughly in uniform it or
independent of the sequence
maybe I'll leave it there and then and
then come back to this question a little
bit so the primary the first thing you
might do with a noun report data is you
want a base call so you want to take
these events and predict which sequence
generated this this group of current
samples and to do that Oxford nanopore
provides a map from sequence for all
possible fibers to what the the measured
event should be and this is just a set
of Gaussian distributions for example
when the sequence aaac is in the poor we
expect to see events with mean current
level 54.2 p collapse standard deviation
point nine and if you take that you
build say hidden Markov model you can
then take your event table and then
predict which sequence each one of these
events corresponding to now this is an
inherently very lossy method in that by
going from from from events to sequences
if you just work with the sequence data
which has about a fifteen percent error
rate you're you're not able to recover
all the information that was in these
raw samples and so we try to work with
the raw event data as much as possible
so I mentioned a few slides ago that the
nanopore sequencers very portable as a
test of the portability of the nanopore
sequencer my colleagues Nick Loman and
Josh quick they took the men I on and
all the associated equipment that you
need to make mid-on libraries they
packed it up into about three suitcases
and took it to Guinea in West Africa to
perform real-time surveillance of the
Ebola outbreak this is this is the
sequencing setup that they had there in
one of the the field clinics and these
are the three main oh ions that they
used to sequence they were able to do
about 140 bowl samples based on
applicants over a period of a few months
and as I said directly in the field
hospitals engage so my contribution to
this project was developing a way of
calling snips from the nanopore data you
by using the signal data
and as the current levels are dependent
on multiple basis these k-mers we can't
treat each snip into individually so we
can't just say ok let's look at all
possible one based mutations of the
Ebola genome and then test each snip we
have to cluster them together into
groups and the way that we do that is by
generating will be called candidate
haplotypes so say we have a position of
the Ebola genome that has we think might
have two snaps either see in this
position or T here we would generate for
possible haplotypes one with no snips
one with just the c1 just the tea and
one with both the sea and the tea we
then I test them calculate the
likelihood of each apple type using the
signal data and then pick the the
haplotype with the maximum likely to
hood as our output for this region in
this example is just the g2 t mutation
here now the the most important thing is
this function here what is this function
PDMS looks look like so we've built a
hidden Markov model for computing this
and our hidden Markov model is designed
to account for three different types of
heirs the first type is where the signal
is over segmented so where one group of
sample is broken up into many different
parts rather than just being a segment
for a single tamer and then the opposite
type of area where the signal is under
segmented where what should be multiple
k-mers was merged into one long segment
and also where the nanopore sequencing a
sequence and move through too quickly to
register enough samples to detect as a
unique event so our hmm has three states
then we have these M States we call
which match events to k-mers be states
if we've observed extra events for a
particular camer and K states if we
didn't ever observe any events for a
particular pay more to handle over
segmentation each states under
segmentation is short events in the case
days then we just have to say the normal
use the forward algorithm to compute
this function
and where this term is the emission
distributions that came from this table
mapping k-mers two gaussian
distributions and these are transition
probabilities that depend on how likely
it is that you're going to miss a
transition determined by how similar the
Gaussian distributions are four adjacent
cameras in your sequence okay so that's
the basic hmm that we use I'm now going
to talk about methylation so the idea of
methylation detection using the nanopore
sequencer is that because you're sensing
the actual perturbation of the current
from the DNA molecule any sort of
chemical modifications of that DNA
molecule might affect the current in a
different way this was shown a few years
about going in experimental nanopore
sequences by Markakis ins group and UCSC
and I've been working with Winston temp
at Johns Hopkins University of
validating this and building predictive
models from the from Oxford nanopore Zi
on instrument so it winds in tempted is
he took a set of E coli DNA he
synthetically methylated it with a CPG
methyl transferase to build a training
data set that we could use to relearn
these emission distributions for
variance of the k-mers the contained
methylation or not so here's what range
distributions look like for a few
different examples so this isn't in the
context of ATG ACG where this C can
either be methylated or not so in the
red here is the methylated version of
the camer and in blue is the
unmethylated version and we see that
there's quite a large shift upwards of
the signal in the methylated version
where the distribution is now centered
around 63 pico lamps whereas for the
unmethylated version it's about 59 p
collapse this would be relatively easy
to call methylation off of single reads
in this context now other sequences are
more difficult here's a different
context atg gcg and we see that the
methylated version and the unmethylated
version are quite strongly overlapping
and we probably wouldn't be able to get
singled
ace methylation resolution in this
context but if you pile up a lot of
reeds and sequins to say 30x we could
probably then distinguish between the
the percentage molecules that are
methylated or not in that collection so
having trained this methylation model we
wanted to run it on on real human data
to see how well it works so we've
sequenced a small amount of the na 12
878 cell line and use our trained model
to predict whether cpg islands that are
covered by nano portrayed are methylated
or not so in on the y-axis here is the
percentage of cytosines in cpg islands
that are methylated according to our
nanopore predictive model and on the
x-axis is aluminum bike sulfide data for
the same cell line and we see that our
nanopore measurement is largely
correlated with the the bike sulfide
data and in particular we pick up the
correct biology here in that the cpg
island in our upstream of jeans they're
lying in promoter regions tend to be
unmethylated it based on both of my
sulfide measurement and the nanopore
measurement whereas intergenic CPG
Islands tend to be methylated now we
also performed a negative control
experiment here where we piece you're
treated the human DNA prior to nanopore
sequencing as pcr will get rid of the
methylation mark and if we run our same
nanopore predictive model on that data
we predict very low methylation for that
human data which my mind validates that
our predictive model is in fact picking
up methylation correctly for cpg islands
right in a few minutes I have left here
I'll just talk about some of the
problems that I think are going to be
upcoming for nanopore analysis so right
now that the common workflows are will
will sequence 88 on the nanopore will
then take the events base call them use
the base called reads to map the
nanopore read to somewhere in the
reference genome and then we'll use the
signal data to call snaps from and this
is a lossy procedure because because the
error rate of the novel readings is so
high submarines just aren't going to map
with
fifteen percent error rate so what I'd
like is to skip the base calling step
and take the raw nanopore signal and
align the signal to the reference genome
and then just do all the analysis and
signal space rather than this
intermediate step of our base calling so
within my group we've been investigating
using spatial indices like the KD tree
which works quite well for small genomes
but the question is whether we can scale
this method up to two human genome size
data sets so the structure of the KD
tree is really just taking the reference
genome turning it into a k-mers based on
the events and what you'd expect the
event signal to look like for each
position of the reference genome and
then indexing it and doing nearest
neighbor searches and clustering them
for the whole nanopore read we have a
blog post on my group's blog about this
process if you want to read more about
it and the thing we're interested now is
seeing whether we can scale and then
really going back to papeles question
earlier is how much we information can
we extract from the time that the signal
is it through the nanopore in particular
to improve things like homo polymer
calls so because we're working on these
six more models we don't expect to see a
difference in signal if 6 a's go through
the nanopore or 20 a's go through the
map or but would you like is the events
to be stretched out longer and then use
the fact that the events would be longer
to to predict how many home upon the
length of these homo polymer runs as I
said earlier the the duration
distribution isn't particularly well
behaved because of the stuttering effect
of the nanopore but there is information
there that currently nobody's using and
then it's something that a lot of people
are interested in yeah curious Kim
movies I don't like you
of nanoporous how can they be applied to
concert according to your own research
hit the wall at 0.57 image clearly will
generate too many erroneous calls for in
for human genome or even bacterial I
don't even know how to go to bacterial
change sure I think for cancer the
important thing so when if we take take
a if we assemble nanopore data and
calculate a consensus sequence for the
de novo assembly we get about point
three percent error rate of the final
sequence of a pal Val saying is that
error rate is too high for applying it
to cancer genomes but the important
thing here is that point three percent
remaining heirs aren't distributed
uniformly through the genome they're
almost all in houma polymer runs so
certainly we can't apply nanopore
sequencing to finding homo polymer
length differences in cancer but I think
for the average portion of the genome
even if we have 30 X we can make quite
conference nap calls because those are
the those are fairly well behaved
regions of the genome for going back to
this in bowl of work we validated our
snip calls across the bowl genome and at
30 x coverage we had very few false
positives most samples 0 false positives
some samples one false positive so as
long as we just focus on the new a no
poor accessible part of the genome as I
think we can get good calls my ask you
something yes suppose we focus on now
for accessible part of zanshin to laser
go home from a tire tracks yes
distinguishing give him single
nucleotide wrap and tumor in acid to
nucleotide run a a versus a
every how will you do is this I i don't
think i've found that I think you can as
long as the flanking sequence is
different like x AAA y where x and y
aren't a i think you can call those
without a problem right and the third
thing is is how well we can make these
hmm based inference algorithms scale if
we sequence a human genome the 30x we're
going to have a hundred giga bases of
sequence data but this actual signal
data is an order of magnitude more and
and how can we make that scale such so
we can make the analysis as fast and
cheap as the sequencing so those are the
three big problems i'm keeping in mind
and things that we're working on in my
group I'll just end with with some
acknowledgments I'd like thank jonathan
curiously Mathai david in my group who
work on the algorithms fills is our day
is a research technician who's helping
us do the sequencing within my group and
then my collaborators Nick Loman and
Josh quickly the University of
Birmingham in the UK Winston timp and
rachel workman at Johns Hopkins
University and the members of the
pan-cancer project all of our codes down
here it's a bottom if you're interested
so going back to your plots with respect
to find Ellen SP calls yeah first of all
you know the question that i'm going to
ask is because and how confident are you
with this and perhaps as importantly if
you go one slide back so I especially
notice Noah break somewhere close to the
button with respect precision if you
remember the dream challenge
demonstrates an hour break winning all
right I was compared to your validation
so you know the dream challenge of
simulated data of course um Ted of value
in the gene chose that is the oh this is
a controversial question I think um
certainly we need we need to reconcile
what's going on like something i didn't
say this is aggregated across all
samples so if
you have one sample where Noah break
made a lot of mutation calls it's going
to have very low precision if they
didn't tend to tend to be validated what
the dream channel with the gene
challenge is looking at is single sample
performance and each group can submit
make multiple subs and admissions there
so there's there's some parameter
parameter optimization going on the
dream challenge it isn't done here this
is looking at 50 samples and collective
behavior what I shouldn't show that I
didn't cuz I don't have time for is the
performance on the 50 different samples
what's the precision per sample per
caller and then that would probably look
different than looking at these
aggregated numbers for both in dells and
and SPS so with respect to this piece
how did you call in sp that that is yeah
so we we call des filles using two lines
of evidence so we looked for a
consistent pattern of soft clipper reads
within the predicted region of the
breakpoint and we also looked for
whether the tumor sample had a much
higher proportion of discord and read
pairs within that region and if either
of those conditions past we said it was
a validated call it's not the exact
weight point we didn't require an exact
breakpoints no certainly like you asked
how confident I am in this there's
there's an entire structural variation
working group as you know in Pam cancer
who are also looking at the validation
data this was our first pass at getting
numbers um there is more work to be done
certainly I didn't understand in Europe
eating chicken
Chenault of my education was the totally
blind experiment or was it a control
experiment like people not three years
ago also done a portal founder headed
paper where they even detected
phosphorylation because it wasn't white
experiments you know you wear furs
violation was to look forward and I was
not completely sure whether like you
showed some result but was it blind or
was it completely blind or you you wear
this identification sir human experiment
we didn't know where the modifications
were going back to this so the
experiment was like this we have e coli
DNA we PCR tree yet and then we
methylated as well and we sequence both
the PCR which is completely unmethylated
and the synthetically methylated version
using two parallel nanopore runs and
then we that's our training data set to
distinguish between unmethylated
sequence methylated sequence we then
took human data native just a DNA
extraction no pcr we sequence it and
then predicted methylation not knowing
anything about the methylation patterns
in human and then we also took the same
DNA we PCR treated it and ran our
prediction algorithm on the exact same
on that and on the pc are treated and
that's the next slide here and this is
the difference between methylated and
completely unmethylated so in in this
version in human data set we had no
prior knowledge of methylation patterns
that wasn't in our algorithm at all we
just use the signal data to predict
whether it's methylate
just want to be nice DNA was did you
purify the DNA out what a human um it
was it was purified either it was just
normal DNA extraction kid no he's don't
know so then why we see this gene effect
that's just because the promoters tend
to be unmethylated right before you fill
out so you're saying that like if we
throw out the histones when we wouldn't
see the the cpg methylation signal I'm
just saying the near the CPG signal is a
koala tonight the DNA property okay you
know if you purify the DNA and
methylated in b12 we didn't methylated
in vitro no no this is this is native
DNA all we did was extract and sequence
so curious it the nanopore has trouble
with homo polymer runs but is it fine
with variable and short tandem repeats
or you're basically going through
mutation as long as it's cycling and you
can pick it up and you could say you
know there's a ga ga gee you should be
able to predict the link
were you able to detect further from the
nanopore uh yeah this is probably the
most sequence human sample and people
have spent a lot of time so this is one
of the genome in a bottle samples as
well so there's a TEDx data which is
hunter kb reads and there's very good
collections of structure variations so
that could be used as a resource but
it's not something that we've looked at
any more questions as we switch
now let's think Jared Jenk tried to make
sure we didn't